messieurs les présidents monsieur le
premier ministre
messieurs les premiers ministres
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs les officiers
généraux
sous-officiers gendarme adjoint
volontaire d'activé ou de réserve
personnel civil de la gendarmerie
nationale chère madame beltrame
chère madame nikolic beltrame
chères familles
mesdames et messieurs il était environ
11 heures ce vendredi 23 mars 2018
lorsque le lieutenant-colonel arnaud
beltrame s'est présenté avec ses hommes
devant la grande surface de trèbes dans
l'aude un quart d'heure seulement leur
avait suffi pour être sur les lieux que
savait-il à ce moment là ni terroristes
qui s'y étaient retranchés
il savait qu'il avait un peu plus tôt tu
es le passager d'un véhicule
jean-michel jean-michel mazières et
grièvement blessé son conducteur
renato gomes da souza qu'il avait fait
feu sur des crs aux abords de leurs
casernes et blessé l'un d'entre eux à
l'épaule
le brigadier frédéric poireau que dans
ce commerce où il s'était retranché
il avait abattu deux hommes à bout
portant
hervé sosna un client et christian
medvès le chef boucher
nous pensons
en cet instant assez blessé à ces morts
no more et à leurs familles dans le
recueillement
il savait aussi que le terroriste
détenez une employée en otage qu'il se
réclamer de cette hydre et islamiste qui
avait déjà tant meurtri notre pays qu à
vis de données en ce meurtrier chercher
la mort chercher sa mort cette marque
d'autres avant lui avaient trouvé une
mort qu'il croyait glorieuse mais qui
était object une mort qui serait pour
longtemps la honte de sa famille la
honte des siens et de nombre de ses
coreligionnaires une mort lâche obtenu
par l'assassinât d'innocents
l'employé prise en otage était de ces
innocents pour le terroriste qui la
tenait sous la menace de son arme
sa vie ne comptait pas pas plus que
celle des autres victimes
son sort sans doute allait être le même
mais cette vie compter pour arnaud
beltrame elle comptait même plus que
tout car elle était comme toute vie la
source de sa vocation de servir accepter
de mourir pour que vivent des innocents
tel est le coeur de l'engagement du
soldat être prêt à donner sa vie parce
que rien n'est plus important que la vie
d'un concitoyen
tel est le ressort intime de cette
transcendance qui le porte est là
était cette grandeur qui a sidéré la
france
le lieutenant colonel beltrame avait
démontré par son parcours exceptionnel
que cette grandeur coulait dans ses
veines
elle irradiait de sa personne elle lui
valait l'estiment de ses chefs
l'amitié de ses collègues et
l'admiration de ses hommes
à cet instant toutefois d'autres
même parmi les braves aurait peut-être
transiger ou hésité mais le lieutenant
colonel beltrame s'est trouvé face à la
part la plus profonde est peut-être la
plus mystérieuse de son engagement il a
pris une décision qui n'était pas
seulement celle du sacrifice mais celle
d'abord de la fidélité à soi-même de la
fidélité à ses valeurs de la fidélité à
tout ce qu'il avait toujours été et
voulu être à tous ceux qui le tenait
ce choix lui ressemblait tellement que
sa mère apprenant qu'un gendarme
accomplissez ce geste a instinctivement
presque charnellement reconnu son fils
elle a su que c'était lui
avant même de savoir lucide
déterminé le lieutenant colonel beltrame
appris auprès du terroriste la place de
l'otage il était un peu moins de 12h
un soldat aussi aguerri gendarmes
d'élite cité au combat en irak santé
sûrement qu'il avait rendez vous avec la
mort mais ils avaient rendez-vous avant
tout et plus encore avec sa vérité
d'homme de soldats de chef
ce fut la source de son immense courage
pour ne pas manquer aux autres il faut
ne pas se manquer à soi même
le lieutenant colonel beltrame a fait ce
choix parce qu'il se serait
éternellement reproché de ne pas l'avoir
fait je sais ce que peuvent ressentir ce
qui était à ses côtés ce jour-là il
revoit s'écouler lentement les minutes
qui ont conduit à cette décision
il revoit le lieutenant colonel beltrame
déposer son arme lever les bras et
s'avancer seul vers le terroriste ils
savent désormais que tout s'est joué là
ils savent aussi qu'ils n'auraient
laissé sa place à personne car l'exemple
vient du chef et l'exemplarité était
pour lui comme pour chacun d'entre vous
une vertu cardinale
au coeur de tout vrai courage se trouve
une grande force morale elle seule elle
ne se discute pas elle pousse à agir
avant même ce 23 mars
le lieutenant colonel beltrame était de
ses fils que la france s'honore de
compter dans ses rangs
l'hommage que la patrie lui rend ce jour
nous le rendons aussi aux actions
remarquables qui avaient jalonné sa
carrière comme elles jalonnent la vie de
tant de ses camarades au sein de nos
armées dès sa sortie de l'école saint
cyr il avait choisi la gendarmerie il en
avait fait sa seconde famille parce
qu'elle était proche de la vie de ses
concitoyens et qu'elle exigeait de lui
chaque jour
l'excellence une gendarmerie qui paient
chaque année son tribut à la sécurité et
à la protection des français
une gendarmerie qui cette fois encore
s'est illustré par sa maîtrise et sa
force et je rends ici hommage aux forces
de gendarmerie de l'aude à leur chef le
colonel sébastien guay au chef du gign
de l'antenne de toulouse et à ses hommes
dont deux ont été blessés
en menant la somme tous sont durement
éprouvé par la perte de leurs camarades
je sais et les français savent qu'ils
ont tout fait pour que le pire
n'advienne pas comme leurs camarades de
la police et du renseignement et de tous
les services de la préfecture
les français n'oublient pas non plus
le tribut payé par toutes nos forces de
sécurité sur le sol national et par nos
armées sur les théâtres extérieurs
tous ont droit à notre respect
inconditionnel et tous je le sais
partage la certitude profonde qui a
animé le lieutenant colonel beltrame
celle que son destin ne lui appartenait
pas tout à fait qu'il avait partie liée
avec quelque chose de plus élevé que lui
même car ils étaient 1 engagés et ils
avaient juré de faire corps avec un
idéal plus grand et plus haut
et cet idéal c'était le service de la
france dès que nous eûmes a pris son
geste
à l'issue incertaine nous tous français
avons tremblé d'un frisson singulier
l'un d'entre nous venait de se dresser
droit lucide et brave il faisait face à
l'agression islamistes face à la haine
face à la folie meurtrière et avec lui
sur jc du coeur du pays
l'esprit français de résistance par la
bravoure d'un seul entraînant la nation
à sa suite
cette détermination inflexible face au
nihilisme barbares convoqua aussitôt
dans nos mémoires les hautes figures de
jean moulin de pierre brossolette des
martyrs du vercors et des combattants du
maquis soudain se levèrent obscurément
dans l'esprit de tous les français
les ombres chevaleresque des cavaliers
de reims et de pâtes et des héros
anonymes de verdun et des justes des
compagnons de jeanne et de ceux de
kieffer enfin de toutes ces femmes et de
tous ces hommes qui un jour
on avait décidé que la france la liberté
française la fraternité française ne
survivraient qu'au prix de leur vie et
que cela en valait la peine car
l'intolérable jamais ne peut l'emporter
le camp de la liberté celui de la france
est confrontée aujourd'hui à un
obscurantisme barbares qui n'a pour
programme que l'élimination de nos
libertés et de nos solidarités les
atours religieux dont ils se parent ne
sont que le dévoiement de toute
spiritualité est la négation même de
l'esprit car il nie la valeur que nous
donnons à la vie valeur nié par le
terroriste de trèbes valeur nié par le
meurtrier de mireille knoll qui a
assassiné une femme innocente et
vulnérable parce qu'elle était juive et
qui ainsi a profané nos valeurs sacrées
et notre mémoire
non ce ne sont pas seulement les
organisations terroristes les armes et
d'edf
les imams de haine et de morts que nous
combattons ce que nous combattons
c'est aussi cet islamisme souterrain qui
progresse par les réseaux sociaux qui
accomplit son oeuvre de manière
invisible qui agit clandestinement sur
des esprits faibles ou instables
trahissant ceux là même dont il se
réclame
qui sur notre sol en doctrine par
proximité et corrompt au quotidien c'est
un ennemi insidieux qui exige de chaque
citoyen de chacun d'entre nous un regain
de vigilance et de civisme
il s'agit là
et depuis plusieurs années d'une
nouvelle épreuve mais notre peuple en a
surmonté beaucoup d'autres c'est
pourquoi il surmontera celle ci aussi
sans faiblesse et sans emportements avec
lucidité et avec méthode nous
l'emporterons
grâce au calme et à la résilience des
français peuple rompu aux morsures de
l'histoire patients dans le combat
confiant dans le triomphe ultime du
droit et de la justice
comme si souvent la montrer notre longue
et belle histoire nous l'emporterons par
la cohésion d'une nation rassemblée
pendant ces heures interminables
s'achevant par la mort du terroriste et
le transfert du lieutenant-colonel vers
l'hôpital de carcassonne
dans la salle de commandement du
ministère de l'intérieur nous avons tous
espéré chef des armées
j'ai moi aussi
ô combien espérer
le petit matin hélas nous apporter la
nouvelle de sa mort comme un coup au
coeur pourtant malgré la tristesse
malgré le sentiment d'injustice
la lueur qui l'a allumée en nous ne
s'est pas éteinte elle s'est au
contraire trop âgés alors que le nom de
son assassin déjà sombré dans l'oubli le
nom d'arnaud beltrame devenait celui de
l'héroïsme français porteurs de cet
esprit de résistance qui est
l'affirmation suprême de ce que nous
sommes de ce pourquoi la france toujours
s'est battu de jeanne d'arc au général
de gaulle son indépendance sa liberté
son esprit de tolérance et de paix
contre tout les hégémonies tous les
fanatismes tous les totalitarismes
puisse son engagement nourrir la
vocation de toute notre jeunesse éveillé
ce désir de servir à son tour cette
france pour laquelle un de ses meilleurs
enfants
après tant d'autres vient de donner
héroïquement sa vie clamant à la face
des assoupi des sceptiques des
pessimistes
oui la france mérite qu'on lui donne le
meilleur de soi oui
l'engagement de servir et de protéger
peut aller jusqu'au sacrifice suprême
oui cela a du sens et donne sens à notre
vie et je le dis à cette jeunesse de
france
qui cherche sa voie et sa place qui
redoutent l'avenir et se désespère de
trouver en notre temps de quoi rassasier
la fin d' absolue qui est celle de toute
jeunesse l'absolu est là devant nous
mais il n'est pas dans l'errance
fanatiques ou veulent vous entraîner des
adeptes en une du néant
il n'est pas dans le relativisme morne
que certains autres proposent il est
dans le service dans le don de soi dans
le secours portés aux autres dans
l'engagement pour autrui qui rend utile
qui rend meilleurs qui fait grandir et
avancer
telle est la voie montré par arnaud
beltrame cet engagement je le retrouve
chez nos militaires nos pompiers
nos policiers nos personnels soignants
nos professeurs tous nos fonctionnaires
engagés partout sur le terrain chaque
est un sel en est précieuse à notre pays
en sauvant cette jeune femme le
lieutenant-colonel arnaud beltrame a
conjuré l'esprit de renoncement et
d'indifférence qui parfois menace il a
montré que le socle vivant de la
république c'est la force d'âme
je le dis à son épouse à sa mère à ses
frères la leçon qu'il nous a offerte et
je le sais d'un prix inacceptable même
si c'est le prix que chaque soldat est
prêt à payer la gratitude de la patrie
et les honneurs rendus ne vous
ramèneront pas l'être que vous aimiez
tant et dont toute la france a découvert
ces derniers jours le goût du bonheur
l'amour qu'il portait à sa famille
le sens de l'amitié ce héros était un
homme avec son histoire ses liens ses
sentiments ses questionnements et lui
même avaient ces héros qui étaient les
grands soldats français arnaud beltrame
rejoint aujourd'hui le cortège valeureux
des héros qu'il chérissait
il vivra en vous par vous dans votre
souvenir dans vos prières
mais ce que nous vous devons c'est qu'il
ne soit pas mort en vain que ça le son
demeure gravé dans le coeur des français
sa mémoire vivre à son exemple demeurera
j'y veillerai je vous le promets
votre sacrifice arnaud beltrame nous
oblige il nous élève il dit comme aucun
autre
ce qu'est la france ce qu'elle ne doit
jamais cesser d'être et qu'elle ne
cessera jamais d'être tant que des
femmes et des hommes décideront de la
servir avec courage sens de l'honneur
amour de la patrie que vous avez
démontré à ces mots vous avez donné
l'épaisseur de votre vie et les traits
de votre visage au moment du dernier
adieu
je vous apporte la reconnaissance
l'admiration et l'affection de la nation
toute entière
je vous fait commandeur de la légion
d'honneur et je vous nomme colonel de
gendarmerie
vive la république vive la france